okay so uh we have two more talks in
this session uh first by Benny kiml
field on measuring the importance of
database
elements okay good thank you so uh yeah
you can see the slides okay you can hear
me well all right so first thank you for
H having us
online and uh I I've been U watching the
workshop uh live during the week every
day a great Workshop great uh talks and
I could also recognize the uh voices of
great people so it's a Pity that we
cannot um be there due to the uh
circumstan circumstances and I I'll do
my best to conve the uh story and so
I'll talk about the importance of
database elements
and
uh I'll start with the importance of
database doules but you know I didn't
synchronize with Daniel he essentially
said everything that I wanted to
say you can go directly to the
questions uh but yeah I I'll I'll put
the stress on some other aspects but so
this is the work with a great colleagues
especially eser lip sheets was behind
the most of the work and Leo and Mel and
Danielle and frost so uh importance of
database stles so here's a toy
example um so uh we have a query saying
uh that there exists a case where a
person who is uh paid low manages a
person who is paid High okay uh and
then uh contrast to say the
and then we look at the database the low
paid the high paid and the database says
uh yes there are cases where this
happens and we say um why is it the case
we want an explanation of why it happens
and the situation is that we have a a
limited attention budget we do not want
to get all of the homomorphisms all of
the answers all the assignments of the
variables but rather a concise
explanation and
we want this explanation to um stress
the parts that are more impactful you
can give me like an arbitrary
homomorphism um uh but I would like to U
uh be able to measure quantify the
importance of the tles according to
their impact on this query their uh
responsibility for actually making this
query happening so you can see here uh
for example that the the there's a
person who is managed by several people
who are low paid and that explains many
of the occurrences though this person is
probably a overpaid or a person uh with
a low salary who manages many people
with a high
salary uh so this person might be
underpaid okay so if we if we stress
these uh or we use these stles for an
explanation we get a much bigger or
bigger part of the story okay so this is
coming from the descriptive
Viewpoint um and we can also look at it
from the uh prescriptive Viewpoint okay
uh suppose that this is an issue like uh
this is something that shouldn't happen
maybe in reality or maybe this shows
some problem problems with the data so
you would like to uh fix it repair it
and now we have a limited repair uh
budget so then we we would like to uh
start working or to put our uh uh
partial effort or or effort in partially
fixing the database on the hotspots on
the tles that will maximize the benefit
of our time even if we're not going to
fix it uh fully okay so uh this is a
example in this case you know this
responsibility uh quantity just a
counting degrees it can be more
complicated if you have something like
you know X manages Y and Y manages Z and
then x and z family members then the
contribution of AO can be more
complicated okay uh um more serious use
case um is for example in this work of
Doo Davidson Ando where they looked at
uh the problem of data credit
distribution okay and they uh
um uh they wanted to quantify the credit
or to credit uh data sets according to
their contribution to uh scientific
publication okay data sets and uh data
curators okay
so um they have a database of the
Publications and
references between Publications and the
data sets and um
the interesting thing is that you know
they use the generic
explanations or or um uh say
contribution quantities uh from the
database because they just had a
relational database and in this
relational database every publication is
a t you see every
uh rectangle here is one a tle and every
data curator is a tle so uh the use
generic uh quantities for the U uh
contribution by the way I use
contribution uh
responsibility uh importance I use them
as synonyms okay and and you can see
that they they've been looking at
several measures provance
responsibility shoply value uh it turns
out you know they they give the same
results here because this is a simple
quy
uh um yeah so so so U I'll be talking
about this in a
second so then uh what I what I first
want to you know uh uh discuss is
whether it is related to the to the
workshop and uh well first the organizer
said that I can talk about it so it is
related by got account uh but um you
know uh lot of the a lot a lot of the
talks and actually in the description of
the seminar uh there's a lot about
annotation of a databases and annotation
by semi- rings in a sense this is kind
of a uh we can view this problem as
going in the opposite flow in annotated
database databases the the uh uh
challenge or the problem is or the
question is how do we annotate the
output apples based on The annotation of
the input in distribution it goes the
other way around how do we uh annotate
the input Apples by by numbers by these
uh contribution scores uh according to
their impact on the output tles now you
can also look at it uh in a a different
uh perspective and say okay let's look
at the obstruction where every
Everything is a every possible tle is
out there and it may have a an
annotation which can be zero and then uh
uh the question becomes How does each
annotation of the
input contribute to The annotation of
the output okay so this is this
obstruction is a uh useful if you want
to talk about um aggregate queries or
contribution of non couples so I'm not
going to develop that okay I just make
the uh I put the connection or a
possible connection on the table
keep that in mind and I'm just going to
talk about
contribution okay um so uh contribution
of the
tles there are um two
principle um General ways domain
independent ways of attributing
contribution to uh toles that have been
studied one comes from causality Theory
and and one from uh gamefield one family
of causality and one family of
Cooperative games and in the case of
cality the idea is that we view the
source stles as uh the the reason as
causing the output tles and then we use
ideas of a level of responsibility to
what extent is each Source tle
responsible to
each output Apple
and then
uh there are
several Works sui the commonality of all
of them um that adopted
several techniques s ideas like a um um
minimal contingency to
get coun
counterfactual dependence on the T I
won't get into this definition
because related to this talk there was
the notion of causal effect the first
came from a work of j h and the second
from Pearl's degree of responsibility
okay in the uh view of uh game theory of
Cooperative
games we view the topples as playing a
game they play a cooporate
gain where different Coalition subsets
can um gain their own
utility and then the question is um if
one of these tles play the game or they
collaborate in order to get the utility
of say producing the crancers then how
do we share the profit how do you share
the joint uh
utility okay so this is a different uh
uh way of rephrasing the
contribution and then uh the sharly
value that the Daniel mention and I'm
going to talk about um in the rest of
the talk um is one of the main idea so
one of the concepts of sharing the
profit another one is the BNS of power
index that was also studied very
recently and turns out to be the same as
the causal effect that comes from a
causality okay so
um um Daniel mentioned the shoply value
he mentioned the uh theoretical
justification uh using the the axioms
that I'm also I'm not going to mention
them again explain them
again uh it is applied in many areas
including in machine learning that
mentioned and databases
I do want to give a a quick explanation
because the uh details kind of matter to
um the rest of the talk so what is the
definition uh a Cooperative game is
simply a function from subsets of the
players okay so we have a set of players
and we have a function that map subset
to a number and uh the question is how
to share the wealth among the players
and there is this function that I
explain
immediately but what you can see is that
it has an exponential summation which
makes it computationally
interesting okay so what is this uh
value think of this uh experiment you
start with the players we want to uh
measure the contribution of the red
player the leftmost uh player so we
start building a team okay we start we
take one player it has a score we take
another player
another
score another player it's monotonically
increasing but it's not necessarily the
case okay we go on and on until at some
point you know a random point we choose
our player at that point this player
makes a difference the impact of this
player is the change from 12 to 17 so
the Delta is five and the sharly value
is simply the expected Delta the the
expected change
okay that's all it is and then uh what
we and others did were basically you
know the the the usual application of
the sharly value in order to apply it to
a specific setting you need to choose
your players and you need to choose your
well function so um uh in in in and I
work with Esther and the others and
Daniel um the players are the database
toles and the uh we
function is um uh the result of the
query if it's a Boolean query then it
can be
01 uh we also looked at aggregate
queries the
question R and we you can see it in the
um uh original publication but I can say
more in the end about how we achieve
that but the utility can be the the the
result of the IAL okay say
some
um what else we also looked at the
contribution of tles to inconsistency to
what extent is a specific
tle uh causing us a headache with
respect to the violation of Integrity
constraints okay so for that the utility
was an inconsistency measure and we
looked at several uh different
inconsistency measures ways of
quantifying to what extent is our data
base violating the Integrity constraints
and then Daniel mentioned the T-Rex
system and and I I'll be slightly
more detailed than Daniel but they they
wanted for example to understand why a
cleaning system chose to change some
specific value so they say okay let the
players be the constraints and the cells
of the database and let the wealth be
you know the the the answer to the
question is the cell change to what
extent is this cell changing and uh then
you know the they they found a
contribution of the different
constraints and the S and we also looked
at graph
databases where the players sometimes
the edges and the vertices and the query
was a a graph query like uh regular path
query and so on okay so um uh this is
the game I'll just say that in many of
these instantiations um we we adopt you
know what they butsi and others did in
their concepts of causality where we
look at we distinguish between the
exogenous tle and the endogenous tles
the players are the
endogenous and we assume that there are
some exogenous tles that are not part of
the game they are given for granted and
they they never disappear they never uh
contingency okay so this is one thing
okay so then I said that the computation
is uh uh interesting the complexity is
interesting and several techniques that
were used so one is you know just
translating the formula into some close
form
formula and solve it for example using a
linearity of expectation because sharly
value is an expectation okay so for
example if we look at in
consistency measurement and we um um
measureing consistency by the number of
violations or the numb that the number
of tles that
participate in the uh um violations then
this is the case what else reduction to
queries over problemistic databases okay
so problemistic databases are not always
easy but when they are easy we can uh
use them so I'll say more about this
result next and Daniel talked about
knowledge compilation to
umf and their book is which also talked
about it this week and um well um of
course if you use an expectation or
probability you can also do sampling
there are some interesting things going
on there were you know you you
immediately get an additive approxim o
imation but you can show that it is also
a multiplicative approximation and so on
so let me um expand a little about the
connection to problemistic
databases and uh by problemistic
database I mean to Independent database
so so uh um well if you do not know the
the concept then it's important just for
two slides then uh bear with me but the
is that every tle has a number which is
a probability that the tle actually
exists and all the tles are independent
per evaluation
means um calculating the probability
that the query is true in the database
okay so there's an interesting
connection between Ty connection between
shly Val and prois databases in one
direction for every Boolean uh query
every Boolean uh query sharply of is a
polinomial Time reducible to the
evaluation of theq over a couple
independent
databases and the proof idea is is this
is a structure that we
see you know frequently in sharly values
and prob databases first we reduce the
sharply value to the problem of counting
the number of the sets of size K that
satisfy the CATE that Danel mentioned
that okay then we take our database and
you produce from it several tle
independent databases each time we use a
different same probability for all the
tles what we get is that each database
gives us a a linear
combination over these counts of the
size case sets that satisfy the
inquiry and all of these are linearly
independent this is a Von The Matrix and
uh we solve that the the the equation
then we get the counts okay and this is
a similar approach to what V Brook and
the others did for the Shar score I'll
mention it uh next I'll use
it
next and uh it also arises in the
analysis of proing
databases suchu and Alvi used it the
proof of the big dichotomy theorem and I
used with anine to prove some complexity
results about special protic databases
okay what about the other direction this
is open well we do not know whether shly
of Q and pro quer evaluation over Q have
actually the same complexity or their
polinomial time in the same uh for the
same qu we do know that this is true for
conjunctive PR without self joints both
the tractable cases are the archical uh
conjunctive for okay so uh that was the
first part about the contribution of
couples and now um I I I'll use the rest
of my time to discuss some uh recent
work still unpublished uh with my
collaborators Peter lindler kristo Stan
and their PHD advisor Martin gry and
here we want wanted to use this concept
of Cooperative game shoply value in
order to measure the importance of per
parameters okay let's look again at the
query that we started with uh with a
high salary low salary but now I spell
out ex what exactly I mean by high
salary low salary I say so low is
smaller than 40 high is higher than 90
you know whatever currency uh you
want and so we can ask you know how
arbitrary are these parameters or a you
know how critical are they for uh the
remember I wanted to see whether there
are cases or to what extent there are
cases of um a low manages high so you
know if I slightly reduce a to 30 40 to
35 then I miss
that I get several of these uh
instantiations disappearing if I change
B is likely you know to 95 then most of
the cases disappear if I play with both
of them uh then suddenly there are no um
um cases of this okay so the the the
quer
thoughts um this is also a question that
you can can ask not necessarily about
the uh inequalities but also about the
constants of a conjunctive query here we
have a a very simple Atomic conjunctive
query R 173 X I'll explain what's
interesting about this St the database I
use factorize representation so
basically
um uh I I I do not give all
the combinations rather use a product uh
for concise
representation relational algebra okay
so uh okay we what what's in the
database this is one relation every tle
has either one or seven in the
attributes A and B respectively and uh C
can be anything and D can be anything
the result is a to G all right Ben you
have about three minutes left okay okay
I I'll I'll I'll
be quick I'll mainly explain the problem
anyway well U the the importance of this
uh example what's interesting in this
example is that whatever change you make
to your parameters it won't change the
uh qu okay we have here three parameters
but we can see that one and seven you
know are quite particular whereas three
is really arbitrary but again changing
every each one of them doesn't change
the U uh
output and uh yet you know while P3 you
know behaves totally symmetrically to
the other possibilities if we change P1
and P2 at the same time then suddenly
the answer becomes empty okay so we want
to uh be able to uh quantify the
contribution of the importance of these
parameter values and there are
several ideas that were discussed before
and uh maybe Brit will talk about Cherry
queries um and again we wanted to to
talk about to see the uh the implication
of uh or the application of the shling
value and as Daniel mentioned there is
this
um uh issue that you cannot just throw
away parameters okay like we do in other
settings uh because without these
parameters the query is not well defined
so what do we do and this situation is
what you see what Daniel explained with
features in machine learning where they
use the shop store what is the idea so
here we have an input and these are the
feature values and we want these are our
players and now given a coalition we say
this is the game use these features for
the others throw them away but you know
replace them randomly and your utility
is the um expectation of this value this
is the idea behind the Shar score then
you use sharly the sharly value for this
specific uh Cooperative uh game and we
do the same uh I'll just say it quickly
we do the same with parameters okay we
uh now have a query with parameters QP
and a database and it gives us a result
and given a a coalition we use these
parameters
um we replace randomly uh the others um
well unlike the case of the
classification or regression now the
result the random result is a set of
answers and different changes can cause
a different uh change of the result okay
in the set of tles so we use similarity
the similarity between the U random
result and the actual result uh in order
to evaluate the the the utility of the
Coalition okay and uh we we looked at
several specific similarity measures and
uh study the complexity of them and so
on okay and um you can also look at this
problem from a different perspective say
okay why why do you look at at you know
fixing the Coalition what we are
interested in for some it's more
intuitive what we interested is what
happens when you change the parameters
of the Coalition how does that affect
the query okay so you can also switch
the game let's say Okay replace the
values of the Coalition then uh use the
other values and then the question is or
the utility a group has a high utility
if it's change with respect to the uh um
actual result is high so here use a
dissimilarity okay which we use as K
minus similarity and the interesting
thing is that these give the same shly
value these are different Cooperative
games um but but you can show it's not a
very hard that actually both of them
give you the same sharply value the same
Shar score okay so I won't um I won't go
over the results this they are listed
the a here and uh well I I I can show
the uh writing privately with whoever
asks and I'll just now we conclude so we
talked about contribution manage
measurement in databases this is not new
and we've seen P result based on quality
and we've been looking at the
application of Cooperative Game
Theory and uh I talked about several
deployments database queries database
cleaning quer design um there are tight
connection to provic databases
and there need to there are some
interesting open problems there and
there are many uh interesting directions
for a future work and specifically for
this uh uh seminar I would stress you
know U um better understanding the
connection between semar ring
annotations and uh contribution
annotation okay and that that again has
a impact on on non
monotonic queries aggregate queries and
so on that's all thank
you one F
yes hi Benny thank you very much for
this nice talk uh do you have any
example of query with self joints which
is hard for probabilistic evaluation H
but it's easy for
sapply
um no actually we don't we we we we
don't know this is a this is the open
problem it may be the case we
conjecture that the two have the same um
complexity
okay but uh uh but we don't have proof
for the for it except for the case of
uh joints yes yeah a very good question
this is the the key question yes and and
a little joke your example was very
realistic I spent four years fulltime at
IBM Almaden and I was fing
so
I see I see you know you maybe I knew
that maybe that's what I have in mind
unconsciously because I worked with both
of
you okay so we will continue with more
questions at 12 for sometime but let's
thank Benny again and BR you can
[Applause]
connect